all right let's get to the question
guild daddy's running out of juice here
can we play the song why open this yeah
I want a different sound okay buzzer
very good boy very I'm hopeful vice here
we go guys where it take this question
slow slow it down hello Tiger belly
I'm a 27 year old man from Algeria North
Africa I'm an electrical engineer a
graphic designer
and a poet but my passion has always
been stand-up unfortunately we don't
have a platform for it here especially
that I write my material in English I'm
planning on moving to the US to try my
hand on open mics but what do you think
is the best city for an inspiring comic
to establish themself comfortably love
your podcasts love the vlogs and I think
Bobby is one of the best natural
comedians in the world and remember this
I will open for you one day you're
number one Arab fan Ben Yoseph
[Music]
[Laughter]
Algeria does he have a chance yes
absolutely Kanye come to LA I love you I
love your name I love your ethnicity I
love your perspective I love your
disposition in life I love your ideas I
love your values I love your home feet I
love your hairs on the legs
I like your nipple rings I like your
sound of music
yeah but yeah come to LA that's the face
right that's that's the only answer I
have to give whatever they are open
obviously is not in Algeria but I mean
he says his material is you know face
George you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
what happened I don't know I'll rip you
do I'll take out in the desert and
[ __ ] do things to your skull you know
that he will I'll take a mallet pound
away pound it out there
make a [ __ ] tenderloin sandwich out
your [ __ ] face I just got hungry now
I love you I meant that's what he meant
to say what's this guy say we do get
really the whole thing against ben
youssef i don't care i want to eat the
whole thing again okay we'll do the
whole thing over touch or it is now
start from the bottom up start from the
bottom of work you should I go backwards
okay cheerio this is the best podcast
top 50 UNT's iTunes sometimes we're on
sometimes we're off go go go
I'm hopeful voice hello Tiger bellow I'm
at 27 I'm gonna answer him like he's
this talk alright okay yeah be him I
don't do the accent I don't know what it
fits the North African I'm doing yeah
I'm 24 seven year old about cheerio hi
I'm an electrical engineer you are
that's great a graphic designer
hmm and a poet that's nothing just FYI
that's nothing but my path everyone's a
poet everyone could be a poet but my
passion what is your passion it's always
been stand-up great
unfortunately what we don't have a
platform from it here where where
Algeria that's where you live especially
that I write my material in English you
that's where you live what language you
pause well you have a massive booger on
your left nostril
massive it's hanging down it's hanging
down
I don't know me you need to dig that it
was like some
falling off the edge this episode
there's no I'm planning on coming to the
u.s. to try mine I play I'm planning it
coming I planning on moving to the US to
try my hand at up you should drive man
you should follow your dreams on ok but
like what do you think is the best city
for an inspiring comic published himself
come all the best places Algeria okay
well I love the podcast thanks love the
vlogs and I think Bobby U is one of the
best natural comedians in the world I
think that you are a fantastic human
being yourself I will open for you one
day your number one ERA fan ben youssef
bye Ben give me the next one okay I
would do another conversation with the
guy
[Music]